In this video, we'll look at how we can add content to our Unreal Engine project and then use it in our levels.
So in order to add a feature or content pack, we can do that in a couple different places.
One is the add button inside of the content drawer or content browser.
Or additionally, we can click the FAB button if we would like to download and install third party content from the FAB marketplace.
So let's take a look real quick.
Go in here, we can see our add button.
We can import to current folder if we have assets on our computer.
We can add a feature or content pack, which is what we'll do.
In this case, we already have the third person content pack downloaded.
But we can go over here to content and add the starter content to our project.
This will come with a bunch more materials and static meshes and effects that we can add to our level to give us a good starting place.
Additionally, these different features can be added when you create your project from a template inside of the Epic Games launcher.
And if you want to add content from FAB, the FAB button is right here in the content browser.
And we can see that we can search in here for anything that we want and add it to our project through this window.
All right, so we're going to take a little bit of time here and dive into the starter content pack, playing with some of the assets and fleshing our level out.
So I'm going to go look at these architecture assets.
Pick a wall here and we can start to see a size that this blueprint that we created is a little big.
So we can play with the scale.
We can lock all the parameters together here.
Maybe we'll see what this looks like.
Set it to 0.5.
That looks a little more reasonable for a cube.
Bring that one down and scoot this wall back a little bit.
We can use Alt when we click on the gizmo here to create another copy, which is a great thing when you are prototyping quickly.
Let's see, we can drag in this wall as well.
We can change all of our different snap settings and rotational settings up here.
So I can go ahead and set this maybe to 90 and then press E to pull up the rotate.
Snap it 90 degrees.
Press W to pull back or to get back my translate gizmo.
And then once again use Alt and drag off a couple more copies.
And then let's grab both of these again.
I can do shift or control click to grab those and then Alt to bring over my wall.
I'm flying around through the level using the WASD keys and holding right click.
So that allows me to reposition my camera.
And I'm going to use this to drag these forward.
Get lined up there.
Looks beautiful.
Awesome.
Let's see if we can find some other fun assets to use.
We're going to be adding some stuff in from our Unity scene in just a minute.
So we won't do too much but maybe we can drag in this platform.
And I would like to scale this up a little bit.
Give ourselves a bigger platform to work with.
That looks pretty good.
We can reset various values up here.
And let's put it right there in the middle of our...
Does that look right?
Cool.
And let's add maybe some.
We'll look more into fighting a little bit later on.
Let's see if we look at this.
Looks like we might need to rotate it.
There we go.
Let's add one more light over here.
Rotate it as well.
Maybe one more light in the back.
Perfect.
We want to make sure if we look down here in the bottom right,
we can actually see all the assets that are unsaved in our level.
So every time you import something or change an asset,
or working on a blueprint or something down here or material,
it will show up in this list of unsaved assets.
And if you want to save them all at the same time instead of individually,
we can do that here with this list.
So I'll save everything.
And that looks good to go.
Click on off over there.
Sweet.
So now when we press play, we see our spinning cubes
and we see our cool.
I think additionally, I'd like to move this cube over here.
I'd like to move this one over here.
Move this forward a little bit.
Alrighty.
In the next video, we'll look at how we can take our content from Unity
and bring it into Unreal Engine.